hello welcome to another Science and
Technology q a for kids and others and I
see that we have a bunch of questions
saved up here
um
I see one here from Ellen is color
discrete or continuous
okay it's a question I've never thought
about before but let me see what I can
do and answering that question
so
uh
what
first of all
color as we perceive it
is based on light
being sensed by the cells on the back of
our retinas
and
what what determines the color of a
thing
well there's light that comes from that
thing and there are many different
wavelengths many different frequencies
of light so a thing that looks to us red
will have okay first thing to say is
um
when
you look at light light consists of
electromagnetic waves the waves have
certain wavelengths or frequencies it's
like wiggling on a string except there's
no string and there's no wiggling as
such it's the intensity of electric
fields and magnetic fields moving
through space and it's and what's there
is just the presence of that
electromagnetic field or not but the
electromagnetic field is is varying
trillions of times per second and the
number of times per second that varies
determines the in the end is going to
determine the color that you perceive
but but there are any possible frequency
uh kind of curve for an electromagnetic
wave there are electromagnetic waves
with frequencies of uh you know once
once per second it Wiggles sort of once
a second and there are ones that have
frequencies of once every trillion
trillion trillionth of a second and
different electromagnetic waves have
different characteristics so for example
visible light is around a few trillion
times per second of uh variation of the
of the electronic waves if you go to
lower frequencies you get down into
infrared and then into radio waves if
you go to higher frequencies you get to
ultraviolet and then x-rays then gamma
rays but visible light is a very thin
sliver of possible frequencies of
electromagnetic radiation it's the thin
sliver that happens to be uh at the peak
of what's produced by something of the
temperature of the surface of the Sun
surface of the Sun has a temperature
about 6 500 Degrees I think centigrade
and um a thing at that temperature glows
a certain color it is a white hot thing
and so most of the light it produces is
it's it's it's it's well we'll explain
the the white hot in a second but as you
heat something up up it the the atoms
are jiggling around inside the thing
that corresponds to heating it up and as
those atoms jiggle around they can emit
electromagnetic radiation and the faster
the atoms jiggle the higher the
frequency of the radiation so when the
atoms are jiggling quite slowly you'll
get kind of lower frequency radiation
that corresponds to things like infrared
and so on as you heat it up you get
progressively higher frequency radiation
and that goes from uh from the red and
then it starts producing other colors
yellow and things like this and
eventually you'll get to Blue which is
at the the fastest end of uh of the the
Spectrum but the place where you get
visible light where is is uh corresponds
to
the temperature of the surface of the
Sun
um kind of no coincidence that we kind
of evolved to have eyes that are
sensitive to the kind of electromagnetic
radiation that's in good Supply uh for
our planet based on on the uh radiation
produced by the Sun
electromagnetic radiation produced by
the Sun so in any case the um uh within
that narrow band of frequencies you have
uh one end red light
at the other end blue light and in
between those you have kind of the
colors of the rainbow
um of of of of colors of light
corresponding to those different
frequencies so
here's here's where it gets a little
tricky is our eyes are not determining
oh that is light of a particular
specific frequency our eyes just have
three kinds of color receptors that are
roughly sensitive to red green and blue
and that basically say this particular
piece of light has this amount of red
ish light in it this amount of greenish
light this amount of bluish light
and it's a little mathematically
complicated because what's happening is
if if you for example have a laser a
laser has a a single frequency of light
typically you'll have a red laser a
green laser whatever the the light
coming from the laser will be a specific
frequency of light
when our eyes
uh detect a color what they're doing is
they're saying what's the overlap
between the kind of colors that a a
reddish
sell on our retina detects and the
actual color of light that you're being
presented with
um and the way it works is those three
kinds of cone cells they are on the
retina they they are one of them it's
kind of centered on the the red part of
the spectrum but it has a little bit
it's still so what's eventually going to
happen is a photon of light falls on
that of that um
um
retina and if the photon is of the right
in the right range of frequencies it
will produce an electric result and
you'll get an electrical pulse that goes
down your optic nerve to your brain and
you perceive having obser having seen
that color of light
um but the the photons that your reddish
cone cell will accept have a range of
frequencies it's not just kind of this
particular laser has
um with this very specific frequency is
the only one that it detects it's a
range of frequencies but it's a range of
frequencies that's kind of centered
roughly on the red and similarly with
the bluish and greenish uh
um cone cells so when we perceive a
color as something was discovered uh in
the 1700s I think we we what we're
really sensitive to are these three
components of color
um we're sensitive to how much reddish
light is there in there how much
greenish how much bluish light
and it can be for example one thing that
can happen is
when you really ask what what is the
true color of that thing what you would
have to do is describe the light that's
coming from that thing what how much
light is there of each particular
frequency the whole spectrum of
frequencies how much how much light is
there right in this uh this particular
wavelength you know whatever it is you
know 300 and something nanometers or
something that corresponds to yellow or
something like that how much intensity
of light is there at that frequency how
much intensity of light is there at a
neighboring frequency and so on and you
can plot a graph that shows sort of how
much how much intensity of light is
there at every possible frequency but
when we perceive colors what we're doing
is taking that whole graph of how much
light is there at every possible
frequency and we're just saying tell me
how much roughly there is in the reddish
area how much is there in the greenish
area how much is there in the bluish
area so we're approximating that whole
curve of of how much intensity of light
is there at every frequency by just
three numbers the total sort of reddish
intensity greenish intensity bluish
intensity that means that for example
there are many different
uh sort of curves that will all be
perceived as quotes the same color by us
even though in truth the the actual
frequencies of light the intensity as a
function of frequency of light is there
are many different ones we will perceive
them all as the same because we're just
sampling those three numbers out of that
uh distribute out of that out of that
curve
um and so
and that that
means that for example there's the idea
of hyperspectral Imaging where instead
of just looking at the kinds of things
that our eyes look at red green and blue
you look at for example 512 different
possible uh frequency ranges and you say
how much intensity is there in each of
those frequency ranges and that allows
you to do things that we can't do with
our just sort of unaided eyes you'll be
able to look at something which to us
kind of looks oh it's kind of whitish
but to a hyperspectral camera for
example it will say oh there's a whole
distribution of frequencies here I can
tell that the material that this is made
of is such and such even though to us it
might just look as a like a you know in
in a chemistry lab for example there are
lots of white powders that you'll see in
a chemistry lab
um but to a hyperspectral camera hyper
spectral Imaging system those quotes
white powders might all have very
different distributions of of uh of
light intensity as a function frequency
and so you'll be able to tell oh that's
this chemical that's that chemical and
so on
so
okay so that's a uh what what our eyes
see in the end is just they extract
these three numbers or these three
intensity values for red green and blue
and that's how we perceive colors and
usually the way that um one represents
colors uh uh one can make this thing
called chromaticity diagram which shows
uh uh kind of it's a sort of triangular
shape thing where it roughly is showing
the amount of red green and blue
intensity but since we're saying the
total intensity of the light
has some value you can plot it on kind
of a triangular plot okay so a little
math point if you have sort of a
triangle and you put a point inside the
triangle and then you put a line from
that point to the corners of the
triangle you move that point around the
the lengths of the total length of those
distances to all the corners of the
triangle will be the same so having this
sort of triangular plot it's a
convenient way to plot something where
the total is all the same the total of
three values is always the same and what
you care about is the relative values of
those uh the relative sizes of those
three values so that's the way that
chromaticity plots work because you're
saying I assume we have a certain
overall intensity of light
now What proportion is in the red
Direction green Direction blue Direction
and there are it's a pretty complicated
uh sort of whole setup because for
example if you know it's this much in
this redirection green Direction blue
direction there's a certain region that
is where human Vision can actually uh
detect the uh the light and if you go
outside of that region you get to places
where you know bees that see an
UltraViolet can see it but we cannot
um there's this particular region that
corresponds to the visible uh region of
of visible perceivable colors
so
uh and and there are
a variety of different ways to represent
colors for example when we have a
typical computer display if you look
under a magnifying glass you'll see that
the display has a little uh pixels of
red green and blue and so the way that
the that a color is synthesized on your
computer display is just by having a
certain intensity of the red dots
certain of the green dots and the blue
dots but there are there are a whole
variety of different ways in which one
can synthesize colors so for example
when you uh print uh again it's a little
different because when you're dealing
with something on paper you're dealing
with the light that is
reflected from the paper rather than
when you're dealing with a computer
screen you're dealing with light which
is emitted from the screen
um but there are different
colors that are the primary colors used
for printing then the primary colors
normally used on a computer screen but
you can you can have a whole variety of
different ways to represent colors
there's always three numbers but what
those three numbers are can be different
so for example there's a uh uh the the
the amount of red green and blue is one
thing that's commonly used by computers
there's a thing called a cie
um it's kind of a standard that was set
in the 1930s for how color is perceived
and then there are three parameters
imaginatively named X Y and Z which
don't really quite correspond to
particular colors that we recognize but
are a slightly better way to tell sort
of to represent perceptual color why is
it important to have a different
representation the reason is if you want
to figure out kind of the distance
between two colors you want to figure
out which two colors are so close that a
typical person will not be able to
distinguish them if you have a certain
coordinate system for colors then
depending on whether you're in the reds
or the greens that distance of
distinguishable colors will be different
but if you have a correct coordinate
system for colors then the distance over
which you will get confusion about
colors will be the same independent of
what color you're dealing with and
that's one of the things that's achieved
by the cie uh uh approach to to to
representing colors
so
any case I think the original question
here was about whether colors as we
perceive them are discrete or continuous
the thing I'm just talking about is
relevant to that because when we look at
colors and we look at nearby colors
we've changed the intensities of the
light just a little bit we can ask the
question when are these colors
distinguishable when are they not
for us humans uh there are there's a
certain range of color that places where
the colors are just indistinguishable
then we go slightly further away the
colors will be distinguishable there's
kind of a hack for at least half of half
of the humans which is that um uh
because the
the cone cells
that allow us to detect color are coded
for on the X chromosome in our genetics
um the uh so what's happening is in in
um
in this cone cell there's a protein
called rhodopsin which is the protein
that is that when it absorbs a photon
produces an electrical pulse
and that protein is some whole
complicated collection of amino acids
it's all curled up in a certain way and
it has the effect that it presents it
has this arrangement of atoms so that
when the photon falls on it it will as a
certain frequency it will produce an uh
a um an electron and it will produce
kind of an electrical pulse
but
if you uh the so basically we have
typical person uh who isn't colorblind
has three different kinds of cone cells
a reddish a greenish a bluish one uh
people who uh happen to be colorblind uh
will typically have two different kinds
of um
um
of cells rather than three dogs for
example and I think cats also uh have
are always
um deuteronotropes I think it's called
um which are are um uh preachers that
have just two kinds of cone cells
um and so they they perceive they don't
perceive the same kind of range of
colors that we do now we're not the
winners there are Critters that have a
lot more kinds of concerns than we do I
think the the known uh kind of champion
is the mantis shrimp which I think has
15 kinds of uh of different kinds of
cone cells
um there are fishes that also have um uh
more kinds of cone cells that we do and
so we'll have a sort of richer more
elaborate color experience
but for us typical human has
um uh three kinds of cone cells but it
so happens that the protein that is
the Protein that's used in cone cells is
coded for on the X chromosome and
um the the way our species Works uh
females of the species have two X
chromosomes males have an X chromosome
and a y chromosome but if you have two X
chromosomes they won't uh they won't
necessarily be they won't be the same
they won't have the same coding for that
um uh potentially they could have
different versions of the rhodopsin
protein coded for on them and so that
means that you can end up with if you're
a female of the species so to speak you
can end up with two slightly different I
think it's primarily the blue
um cone cell where this where this
happens
um you end up with two different
versions of it and so that means that
whereas most of us the um uh the X Y
chromosome half of the species
um the uh
always just has one kind of blue cone
cell the the female half of the species
can have two different kinds of blue
cone cells although don't always have
that but if they do
then if your brain has recognized which
of the cone cells on your retina are
blue type 1 and which are blue type 2
you can potentially sense colors more
accurately than those of us who have
just one kind of blue cone cell and I
think if you look at a retina back of
our eye you'll see there's kind of a
a um uh the the kind of the regions
where you'll get things that come from
one of the X chromosomes versus the
other usually are this kind of tabby cat
um like arrangement of kind of stripes
and so on
um across the retina so if your brain
has sort of picked up oh I'm you know
when when you were learning to see so to
speak if it's picked up oh they're a
slightly different uh you sense blue
slightly differently in this part of
your retina than that part of the retina
um you could end up with this situation
where you have better discrimination of
colors than um uh than than those of us
who are who are stuck with just one kind
of cone cell but in any case this whole
question of of uh uh what's the range of
discrimination of colors
um I think that's I I think
let me think about that for a second
um
if you have light coming to your eye and
it's a stream of photons of a certain
frequency
those photons so
your red cone cell for example will be
sensitive to a range of frequencies if
you if you kind of just are looking at
laser light with a particular frequency
hopefully not with a laser shining in
your eye but or at least not an intense
laser but maybe you're looking at a spot
of laser light that's reflected from
something
um the uh then
uh
what will happen is that those photons
from that laser light
will have a certain probability of uh
causing an electron to be produced from
that cone cell and as you shift the
frequency of the light further away from
the the peak of the place of the
distribution where the where the cone
cell can can detect the light the chance
of it producing electron will go down
boy This is complicated I I you know I'm
I'm telling you I I think I have the
experience over and over again uh in
these in these live streams the
questions that I think are slammed out
straightforward questions turn out to be
the ones that have the most complicated
tentacles to them
um and this is an example of one where I
was thinking gosh I should start with a
simple question and uh I'll be able to
answer that quickly
um this is kind of complicated because
what we're now going to get into is
you've got
a
um
yeah you've got what's happening is
You've Got A protein that
when it absorbs a photon of a certain
frequency it will cause an atom to go to
an excited state
and then
I think not exactly sure how how
rhodopsin works but it does I think
um
the result of that atom being excited by
absorbing a photon will be that when it
when it it will emit an electron I don't
exactly know the mechanism by which it
emits an electron but what I can say
yeah I mean that's complicated the the
um uh
um
the question of whether it emits an
electron
it's a quantum mechanical phenomenon
similar to the photoelectric effect
um and
uh this question of whether
let me think about that for a second
um
as you change the frequency of the
photon you have a certain change you
have a change in the probability of
producing an electron and the question
would be does that change happen
discreetly as you change the frequency
of the photon or it does that is that
change a continuous change in the
probability of producing an electron in
other words as you as you adjust the
photon frequency and
that is a good question
and I have to say I would guess that it
is discrete but it has a large number of
different levels
because
um I think what's happening is
um
boy it's complicated okay
um
it's
in this protein you will have certain
energy levels
yeah this is this is complicated I think
the answer is it probably is slightly
discreet but you'd never notice it
because there are so many different
levels that it will appear to be
continuous but I think there may be
another effect that
at any given frequency all you're
getting is a quantum mechanical
probability of something happening and
so it's not this happens or it doesn't
it's rather it really has just a certain
probability of happening and that will
again make it more uh make the result
more continuous but boy that's
complicated okay sorry about that that
was that was much more complicated than
I expected
um
uh
let's see
um
boy
and all kinds of questions there about
color
why does purple look like violet
when purple is made from red and blue
which are on opposite ends of the
spectrum
that's an interesting question I think
uh
you know this question of which colors
look like which other colors versus what
is the actual sort of distribution of
light frequencies for that color
that's an interesting question it's also
the question of what color goes with
what other color is a is a complicated
perceptual thing but I don't think
there's any Simple Theory about
um I think you know companies that
produce kind of color palettes that you
can use
um it's a matter of artistry to kind of
decide this color goes with this color
goes with this color
um it isn't something where sort of the
color Harmony there was a lot of work
done maybe a hundred years ago or a
little bit more of people coming up with
all kinds of color systems
um that attempted to find ways to sort
of pick colors that would go with each
other so to speak
and sort of interesting because in the
case of music and audio kinds of things
there's much more of a theory of what
kind of musical tone goes with what
other musical tone that's what the
pythagoreans figured out back uh you
know more than a couple thousand years
ago
um was the fact that in the end
um the the what the notes that tend to
go together are ones whose frequencies
are in rational ratios like one to two
that's an octave or three to two that's
a perfect fifth and so on and because
those notes are made by strings of
lengths that correspond to their
frequencies
um it was
one could kind of tell this is made from
a string of twice the length Okay if
it's twice the length it will be one
octave down if it's three halves the
length it will be a perfect fifth down
and so on
um and that to assuming that the strings
are sort of perfect strings and so on
that's that's how it works and one has
the idea that that rational number
ratios like three halves and so on
between frequencies will give you uh
sort of uh
um pleasing uh notes that go together in
the audio domain I don't think there is
any such theory for colors and as I say
there are many different systems whether
you're you know Pantone or month cell or
oh gosh there are just many many of
these different um kinds of systems for
colors in fact in in wolfen language we
have a bunch of color palettes we're
just about to expand that to a color
palette repository actually
um where we have sort of artists chosen
collections of colors that go together
so to speak and that have sort of the
same uh the the just sort of colors that
fit together colors that in some cases
have a good contrast one to the next
um because
um
uh that's something that's useful in in
visualizations and so on I will tell you
one little little trick so there's a the
different representations of color so
one is RGB the amount of red green blue
another is Hue saturation brightness
that's another common one where there's
a huge circle that goes from you've kind
of got the angle in Hue space and you go
from red back to red again uh going
through blue and so on as the the thing
that corresponds to kind of a hue angle
that's 180 degrees away from from the
red
um and as you go through sort of the Hue
uh Spectrum you're going through the
different uh
well the different Hues of color whereas
saturation and brightness are
essentially the amount of weight that
you're that you're merging into that in
the case of of RGB color space white is
just equal amounts of red green and blue
um so these are just different
representations of the same three
numbers but one of the things that's
kind of a fun trick is if you're looking
in in Hue saturation brightness space
and you want to get a succession of
colors that are sort of each one is as
different as as possible from the ones
that have come before a convenient way
to do that is you've got this Hue wheel
you've got this kind of angle and Hue
space and a good way to get sort of a
succession of different colors is to do
the same trick that plants do when they
put out Sprouts at different angles
trying to make sure that the Sprouts
that are coming out higher up have as
look little kind of overall shading of
of lower down Sprouts from the sun and
plants and they have a pretty simple
mechanism that does this but one of the
effects of the mechanism is this thing
about sort of minimal shading uh the the
mechanism is I can explain the mechanism
too but the the end result is that the
successive sprouts come out at 137
degrees uh from the one before them or
roughly 137 degrees it's actually the
golden ratio square root of five plus
one over two uh of um
uh
um it's
it's that ratio that's one over that
ratio that ratio is 1.618 it's one over
that fraction of the way around the
circle from the previous uh Sprout that
came out so if you do the same same
trick with colors where you have kind of
a
um successive Hue values are always
picked
um sort of a golden ratio away from the
uh the previous Hue color so it's a
pretty common piece of code to see Hue
of uh fractional part of golden ratio
times n
um where n is an integer counting up and
you're just sort of uh you're looking at
those um uh those numbers that you get
by just adding a golden ratio on that's
that 137 degrees thing on at every step
and that gives you sort of colors that
are uh maximum distance away from all
previous colors in the sequence you've
had
um and that's a that's a convenient
thing to do in Hue space but uh yeah I
don't know the answer to this um uh I
don't really know a theory of what
colors go with what other colors as I
say it usually is an artist's chosen
thing
um
let's see there's a
wow memes says apparently there are male
folk they can have four basil receptors
as well that's interesting okay did not
know that I mean
you know a lot of weird genetic stuff
can happen
you know one can uh rarely people end up
being chimeras of two different
populations of cells that's one of the
one of the really really strange things
that can happen
um and uh uh that's that happens in
early embryogenesis that you get sort of
a mixture of two two basically different
organisms that end up being two
populations of cells and by the way that
that embryogenesis works that the the
way that that um uh you know the way
that you actually create
um a growing organism the cells kind of
know what to do based on I mean every
cell has sort of the full genetic
material that tells it what to do but
what each particular cell does depends
on the presence of of chemicals that are
diffusing through the through the um the
growing collection of cells and you can
end up with two populations of cells
that actually have different fundamental
genetic material they were really from
two different organisms
um two different uh uh
original sort of uh
um egg cells and so on
um but which end up being mixed together
um to make this sort of uh an organism
that's really a collection of two
different organisms so that you can get
the absolutely bizarre thing that you
can you know you sample your cells and
you say this is my genome oh you sample
another one of your cells and it's a
different genome it's a it's a rare
thing but it but that's one of the one
of the things that can happen
um
let's see there was a
there's a question here about from mine
shell about astronomy saying this got an
eight-inch dobsonian telescope what
should they look at first
um the first telescope they're excited
it's possible to discover something
unique
okay a few things to say about
telescopes and so on
one of the things I always find
a nuisance with telescopes is that the
Earth rotates and so when you set your
telescope up and you point it at some
point in the sky it doesn't take long
before and the higher power your
telescope is the shorter time it will
take before it's no longer pointing at
that same thing in the sky and so if you
get a fancy telescope it can have a
motor which will move it progressively
so that to compensate for the rotation
of the Earth but otherwise the thing
you're looking at in a few minutes will
have gone out of the field of view if
you've locked your telescope in place in
a particular direction I have to say
that Saturn has always uh sort of one of
the more impressive things to look at
and actually if you if you go to wolfen
Alpha and you just type in Saturn it
will it should show you the
configuration that Saturn is in right
now of whether it is uh which which
angle the Rings will be at
um relative to to us on Earth whether
you're looking sort of from the top or
whether you're looking from the side it
kind of just a projection of the Rings
but I always think that's one of the
more impressive sort of immediate things
that you can see through a through a
standard telescope
um I think that um if you like sort of
the history of astronomy uh the moons of
Jupiter are are a good thing to look at
that was kind of the big discovery of
Galileo in 1610
um the uh uh I think what was it January
7th 1610 uh Galileo had this um
telescope that he'd managed to improve a
version of the telescope telescope and
have been invented like a year or two
earlier in the Netherlands and um uh
Galileo had sort of an improved version
and there are all kinds of funky History
of Science tales about
um uh Galileo and his um uh well one
slightly apocryphal tale it's not I
think um is that um uh Galileo had
licensed the telescope to merchants in
Venice so that they could run up this
Tower in Venice and go look through a
telescope to see which ship it was that
was successfully coming over the horizon
which ship was actually going to make it
home after it had been doing some
trading uh you know a trip or whatever
else and then they would uh having seen
what ship was coming over the horizon
they would run down the tower and sort
of place bets in the in the in the
market so to speak uh for um
uh about
um uh kind of like modern stock trading
so to speak you know who can get the
information fastest and that Galileo had
kind of license this telescope for all
these terrestrial uses but having done
that it still let him free to kind of go
up to his roof and um go and look at
look at things in the sky with his
telescope I think that story is not not
completely accurate but it's a but it's
a cool story anyway
um but any case in in um January 7th
1610 Galileo uh used his telescope and
looked at Jupiter and saw these kind of
dots of light uh lined up three dots of
light lined up on the on two on one side
of Jupiter one on the other side of
Jupiter
um kind of looking like they were kind
of in a in a in line around Jupiter well
then he looked on a subsequent day and
they'd moved and they were in different
positions and over a period of a couple
of months he plotted out the different
positions that those different points of
light were at relative to the big disk
of Jupiter and then observed that yes
his big observation was that those were
the moons of Jupiter they were things
moving around Jupiter as planets move
around the Sun and that kind of was a
validation of copernicus's idea that the
uh that you would have this sort of
central body like the sun and things
would orbit around it and by seeing that
same sort of thing play out with Jupiter
gave sort of evidence that yes it really
was likely to be the case that the Earth
went around the Sun and not kind of the
earlier ptolemaic theory that um uh the
sun went around the earth and that we
were sort of fixed in place we we
for us our perception is that we're
fixed in place
um and that like the sun moves in the
sky but it is a better physical
description to say
that the sun is fixed in place and we
move around the Sun
from the point of view of mathematics it
actually doesn't make much difference
which of those we say is going on it's
just we'll have different equations that
describe us being fixed and the sun
moves around us versus the sun being
fixed and we move around it the
equations are somewhat simpler in the
end if we assume the sun is fixed and
we're moving around it
um but in some sense you can make the
mathematics work out either way
um it's just when you try to sort of
generalize it to saying what's going to
happen with Jupiter and things like that
then it makes much more of a difference
to say oh yes the right description is
there's a there's a very massive object
at the center and other things are
rotating around it so that's another
good thing to look at I think depends on
uh the somehow many other planets tend
to be to my mind through a typical kind
of uh personal telescope so to speak
tend to be a bit bit anticlimactic I
mean they're slightly bluish they're
slightly uh you know this color or that
color but they're still just little
discs and you can't really see much else
in them
um I have to say that that um uh you
know there are other things you can see
various nebulas and things which um uh
those are always interesting in terms of
what you can see that you'll see for the
first time so to speak uh comets are a
very common thing for people to just oh
I just saw it and nobody had seen it
before
um that's um
that's one thing also minor planets
asteroids and so on that's another thing
you know the surprising thing is that
the sky is quite big in terms of the
sort of the total area and you would
have thought that by now with all of the
sort of uh fancy computerized telescopes
and so on that an amateur astronomer
would never be able to discover
something that sort of the professionals
didn't have an automated data feed uh
kind of giving you the information about
it but that still hasn't happened for
whatever reason it's still the case that
people can say oh I've I've noticed a
comment I've noticed something that
changed in the sky and uh the the
official astronomers haven't noticed
that yet
um and uh you know other things that can
change or things like supernovas
exploding stars
um and so on but comets seem to be the
more common thing that are discovered by
by amateur astronomers
um I have to say I'm I'm
I I have to believe that that's a
limited window before kind of there are
automated systems that can just do
better than uh than uh than any
um kind of because you know what the the
good news about having a telescope is
that you are you know you're pointing in
a particular direction you're seeing
quite a quite magnified view of that
particular
um
that particular part of the sky but
still uh and and usually you know high
power telescope is looking at a tiny
tiny region on the sky
um as opposed to saying let's survey the
whole Sky
um and and so you know if you took a
high-powered professional telescope so
to speak
um it would take it
you know the number of different
directions that it could look in is very
large and it's only something much lower
powered where you can say oh look at
that whole big chunk of Sky all at the
same time
so in any case it remains an opportunity
for amateur astronomers to discover
things like comets and to discover minor
planets uh you know there are there are
a good supply of science fiction stories
of the amateur who discovers the minor
planet that is an asteroid that's headed
right for the Earth and um uh you know
it's it's small enough that it was never
noticed before but it's big enough that
it will cause a lot of trouble if it
actually runs into the Earth
um I did see a couple of months ago now
an experiment that was done of having an
impact uh hit a an asteroid
um to see whether one could get a
spacecraft hitting an asteroid to
deflect the asteroid enough that it
would its trajectory would for example
miss the Earth that particular one
wasn't actually headed directly for the
Earth but the the end result was yeah it
did seem to work to have something to
have a spacecraft just Ram into an
asteroid and it kind of pushed it a
little bit changed its trajectory enough
that if you were to do that when the
thing was still far away from the earth
you would be able to uh you know it
doesn't take very big change of angle to
be able to get the thing to just
completely miss the Earth as opposed to
to crash right into it
um but so I think Asteroid Defense is
alive and well and would actually work
of course you have to see the asteroid
that's coming first and there are a a an
increasing number of uh often I think
now space-based systems to try and look
for that but that's another uh that's
another type of thing is Observer a
minor planet that nobody observed before
I suppose there are other things that
are kind of um
the uh uh the unexpected phenomena I
mean the most exciting stuff to see is
stuff that's truly unexpected where
nobody uh thought that could happen I
mean you know you'd see some meteorite
enter in the atmosphere and doing
something totally bizarre you know
normally uh I don't think you see
anything terribly exciting through a
telescope
um if you happen to you know look at
um a little little meteorite might be um
you know a pretty tiny thing
um gets hot enough when it enters the
Earth's atmosphere that it'll produce
enough light that you can readily see it
um but you know one could certainly
imagine if there was a a meteorite with
some very strange composition that you
might see some totally bizarre thing
happening if you just happen to turn
your telescope to the sky at the moment
when that meteorite was uh was entering
the atmosphere
um
but let's see other things that you can
see you know I I have to say the um
uh the new version of open language
that's just come out the last couple of
days has a bunch of astronomy capability
in it and in particular has Astro
Graphics which allow you to produce
um
nice
uh sort of detailed astronomical images
and we have data on a large number of
stars and so on and that's that's kind
of a Coming Attraction it happens that
right after this the top of the next
hour I am doing a live stream about the
new features of version 13.2 the new
version of language which includes uh
our new astronomy capabilities so just
uh that was an ad for that term that
activity
um but uh uh
that's some let's see other things that
I can think of I I think that's a um
that's a good collection of uh of of
um some basic astronomy kinds of things
I think I've I've um
um
uh
yeah I think that the
um
you know it's hard to say what to look
for when the most exciting thing to see
will be something utterly unexpected and
uh
um but you can't count on that but it
happens from time to time you know
there'll be a there'll be some Supernova
explosion somewhere and uh or some other
I mean most astronomical phenomena
that happen quickly
there's a certain list of no ones that
happen quickly like a supernova you know
the star explodes you won't see anything
there and then suddenly there'll be a
it'll be bright and it'll stay bright
for a few days uh possibly longer than
that there are other kind of variable
Stars where a period of time from weeks
months days sometimes the um uh the
intensity of the star will change it'll
be it'll kind of look strange that way
there are other reasons that can happen
like you know there's um uh dust that
goes in front of a star and so on most
other kinds of things that are sort of
visible on a short time scale are mostly
things orbiting in our solar system
um like like comets for example or like
minor planets where the thing can sort
of just be in range and then its orbit
will take it out of range and so on
things that are more at the level of
stars and such like pretty much the only
thing that obviously happens quickly as
supernovas
um I mean if you had something which is
uh sort of
Way Beyond the home telescope level so
to speak
um of being able to look for exoplanets
some of those have changed the slightly
changed the intensity of of light from
stars as they go in front of the stars
and so on and that can happen on time
scales of water days to weeks to months
and so on
um
all right let me see
uh
okay Luis is summarizing here a much
better summary that I was giving earlier
to say
colors in their Source are continuous in
the sense that you can change the
intensity of light
you can sort of pick any intensity of
light but perception is discrete I'm not
sure about that I I could argue both
ways because when you're saying a
certain intensity of light
light
of a given frequency is a stream of
photons of a certain energy and they are
discrete photons they're just a huge
number of them I mean a typical
um
uh the there's sort of an absurd number
of photons that are that are reaching
your eye at a given time if you're I
think the king crab is one of the
winners in terms of having very
sensitive eyes uh living in the ocean
and so on and I think it can detect 50
photons landing on its eye at one time
is enough to have it have the the you
know the sensation of seeing something
so to speak for us it's probably a lot
bigger than that
um although uh the thing that one
certainly can Wonder is as one goes down
to very very low light levels for for
even us humans the number of photons
that land on every particular part of
our retina will go down to be really
small and so it's a good question that
where the answer is not quite trivial in
very low light conditions when you can
more or less make things out but it's
still it's kind of difficult to make
things out because it's so dark
if you were really recording in a sort
of very precise way from your retina you
would be seeing individual photons
hitting your retina that the image would
not be formed the image one reason it
kind of looks kind of hard to understand
is that it's not it's not being formed
altogether so to speak it's being formed
from Individual photons landing on
different places on a retina
um but our brains smooth that out so we
just say oh it's kind of a fuzzy
slightly fuzzy image our brains don't
want us to know about photons and so on
they don't want it to appear to be
something that sort of fills in in some
weird sort of speckly way
um so that there really is discreetness
in the photons that arrive on a retina
although in a typical scene with typical
light levels where one can see color
because another thing I should say is
when the light levels go down enough uh
cone cells
require more photons to operate than and
our Rod cells which just sense black and
white and so that's why when you're in
very low light conditions you can kind
of see that there's an object there but
if somebody says what color is it you
won't be able to tell because the the
number of photons is not enough to
produce a a signal that you can detect
from your color receptor cells
um
let's see
maybe um
one more thing here uh and none is
asking about what causes some
uh
oh yeah cutoff is commenting
um
about car lights
and
contrast and so on I mean I think one
the thing to understand about how a
retina is set up we have this fobia in
the center of our retina which is where
most of our color receptor cells are
concentrated our peripheral vision off
to the sides is much less color
sensitive I mean it's all confusing
because our brains tend to fill in based
on one thing we know somewhere else kind
of interpolate they'll extrapolate how
how other stuff works so to speak so uh
you know if you say well what color is
the thing to that side you'll you'll
have some sense of what the color is but
it's not completely clear with that
sense is you know it might be because
you've seen that before or some such
other thing but one of the things that
um is is true is that the cells on the
we have a high concentration of cells
right at the central yellow spot on the
right straight ahead on our retinas and
um uh those cells are
they they're the ones that are
they require higher light levels
um and uh to operate and to let us see
color now there's kind of this this
trick if you're kind of um uh
um let's see why does this work there's
sort of a trick when you're out at night
driving or something and you have car
headlights and you're looking at those
if you kind of look slightly to the side
um when the car headlight is is shining
at you
um that will cause the uh
the intensity of light
from the car headlight to be uh
affecting the the rod cells that are not
on your central spot and then when the
car's gone past and you kind of look
straight ahead again
um you are
uh see why does that work the basic
point is
that
[Music]
that intensity of light yeah right it
takes it takes some time for the cells
that have been sort of uh
um
that have absorbed photons and allowed
you to see from from that light it takes
some time for those cells
to recover from the fact that they were
sort of blasted with light and I'm
trying to remember why this works this
way I think I think that the
are the rod cells less sensitive or
recovered more quickly I don't remember
I only remember I only remember the kind
of uh practical hack so to speak
um
foreign
um
there's a question here about um let me
do this and then I should wrap up for
today
um this is this should teach me to never
never start with a question that I think
is easy because they never are when they
when they appear easy they never
actually are
the question happened on about asking
what causes the Northern Lights
I think that one is easy but we'll see
how we do
so
if you go up near the Earth's north
magnetic pole which is these days
somewhere in Canada
somewhere in Northern Canada the north
magnetic pole South magnet pole is
somewhere where there are a lot less
people
um and uh the um the magnetic poles move
around because they're produced by by
currents in the in the liquid core of
the earth and the liquid core of the
earth is continually sort of changing
the way those currents move so the the
magnetic poles of the earth move over
time but right now it's in it's a
northern counter it doesn't it doesn't
move very quickly over 100 Years it'll
move a significant amount but um over
you know year to year it doesn't move
very much
um Okay so
uh
what happens is there's a stream of
particles that come from the Sun in
addition to the sun producing light the
sun produces
um a solar wind of particles and in the
end it also produces cosmic rays of
higher energy but it produces a stream
of particles that come to the Earth
including electrons
and what happens is that
um the electrons get captured by the
Earth's magnetic field it's kind of like
when you have iron filings for example
and you put them you have a bar magnet
and the iron filings will arrange
themselves in this kind of pattern
around the ends of the bar magnets to
follow the magnetic field lines of the
produced by the bar magnets and it's
sort of the same thing happens with the
electrons that come from the Sun towards
the Earth and what happens is that those
electrons will spiral in around the
magnetic poles of the earth and that's
um just like those iron filings line
themselves up at the two ends of the bar
magnets the Earth's magnetic field is
kind of like a giant the field produced
by a giant bar magnet
um and the electrons when they they come
from the sun when they encounter that
field around they spiral around the
poles okay so what so there's there's
many more electrons on near the poles of
the earth than there are elsewhere
because they got captured by this
magnetic field
and when the electrons spiral in they
will
be kind of
uh kicking
um
atoms that are in the upper atmosphere
of the earth so for example one of one
of those electrons that's been spiraling
in it has reasonably high energy because
it's been sort of accelerated by its
magnetic field things like this it will
knock an oxygen atom for example and
that when it hits that oxygen atom it
makes the oxygen it excites the oxygen
atom as the oxygen atom decays again it
produces a photon of light I think maybe
it produces usually most commonly I
think oxygen maybe produces red light
I'm not sure
um the uh in any case the the electrons
that come from
the solar wind captured by the magnetic
field of the earth
um then hit molecules of air basically
um in the atoms from from the uh that
are part of the from the uh nitrogen and
oxygen in the upper atmosphere of the
earth and that process causes those
atoms to produce light
and that light is what we see as the
Northern Lights
and um they tend to have when you first
see them if you're you're just hanging
out in a place where you can see the
Northern Lights or you're on a plane
that's going uh sort of on on the great
circle shortest path from like you know
Europe to the us or something like that
it'll tend to go quite Northern quite
northernly because that's the shortest
path it might go over Greenland or
something like this
um and uh the um uh you will sometimes
see the Northern Lights then when you
first see them they'll tend to be this
sort of grayish color if you let your
eyes get dark adapted for maybe as much
as half an hour
um and get to the point where you're no
longer you you don't um keep on kind of
um blasting those those um
photoreceptors with photons you just let
the photoreceptors really be sensitive
just those small number of photons that
reach them then you can end up with
being able to see the colors in the
Northern Lights and you'll see greens
and reds and so on
you tend to see this kind of curtain
effect
um
and
I'm not sure that I know what that's due
to uh
that
hmm
what does that do too
I'm sort of thinking that that's due to
some features of this magnetic field but
I'm not sure
not sure exactly how that works
but you'll typically see this thing will
look like kind of a slightly bunched
curtain kind of thing
um there are experiments there was a
experiment with decommissioned a few
years ago now but there was an
experiment in Alaska that involved
shooting uh kind of um
electromagnetic radiation
um and uh I think particularly radio
frequency radiation when I say radiation
I don't mean the radioactive radiation I
just mean things that are like made of
rays like like light rays and so on
um but it was an experiment called harp
that was um uh aimed at um uh you you
kind of shoot high energy
um electromagnetic radiation into the
upper atmosphere and you kind of see
what effect it has and you kind of make
artificial Northern Lights and things
like this
um and that was uh it was an experiment
that was done for many years
um although was was recently I believe
decommissioned
um any case
that's some
uh
um
right that's a little bit of the story
of uh Northern Lights well I think we
should wrap up here and um uh I'm giving
a plug for my thing at the top of the
hour of looking at the new version of
language
um but thanks for these questions and I
think we got we got a little bit trapped
on uh these questions about Vision
um so uh
um next time we'll tackle some other
ones and I might say that that um I
think we often get into a pretty
interesting discussions when people ask
sort of Fairly General
uh having questions about how things
work or things that you might see some
version of them in a science textbook or
some such other thing or some sort of
General technology kind of thing and um
I might be able to give you some kind of
uh uh different perspectives on those
types of things and I think those are
are always good things to uh to chat
about in this um in this uh
um in the setup and I'm guessing I will
be off for a week or two
um for uh
um
uh
um
uh over the holiday period but then uh
we'll be back and um uh Happy look
forward to uh more questions more
interesting things to talk about
so okay I guess that's that's some good
for today thanks very much and bye for
now